the movie begins in the san francisco
fbi department two police detectives
namely frank and matthew sneak into the
building using their authority as police
officers they break into a room reserved
only for authorized personnel to steal
data from a computer they are looking
for someone with specific bone marrow
for an unknown reason after a few
minutes of searching they finally land
on a man named peter j mccabe however he
turns out to be a criminal with murder
manslaughter and assault charges peter
is currently locked in solitary
confinement for breaking an inmate's leg
at pelican bay state prison even though
the guy has no formal education past
grade nine his iq is over 150. moreover
he has escaped twice and killed two
policemen in the process the second time
he burned them alive and used their ids
to confuse the police peter mccabe is
not just a fugitive he is an extremely
intelligent sociopath who loves to play
with people's minds the next day
detective frank and the police captain
go to meet peter in the prison the
reason for their visit is unknown until
frank finally meets peter and reveals
that his eight-year-old son has leukemia
he desperately needs a bone marrow
transplant and according to all
databases the only person that matches
is peter despite finding out that he can
save a kid's life peter doesn't want to
get involved he messes with frank and
makes him beg before telling him that he
will think about the matter frank tries
to change his mind by declaring that his
son is peter's only way of redemption
but a criminal like him doesn't seek
redemption all he wants is fun and
freedom frank leaves the prison in
desperation and goes to the hospital to
meet his son max there he is met with
more bad news as the doctor reveals max
only has a few more weeks to live
without a bone marrow transplant she
asks frank to prepare himself for the
worst but he refuses to listen it turns
out that max doesn't know that his
cancer is back he is excited about a new
aviation book that his father gifted him
and has no worries about the world
however upon sensing his father's worry
the kid figures out something is wrong
and inquires if he is going to die frank
tells him about cancer but lies that he
has found a donor willing to participate
the kid is joyous but he doesn't forget
to tell his dad if the transplant fails
he should know that he tried his best
just then frank gets a call from the
prison peter has finally agreed to the
transplant but wants to meet max before
he confirms it frank is a little
skeptical but he promises to bring the
kid the next day in the following scene
peter and max are together in a room
peter asks the kid to call him uncle
pete and talks to him for a while before
promising to be his donor max runs to
his father in excitement but the
criminal has a bunch of demands before
they proceed with written consent he
wants to get out of solitary confinement
and be able to socialize with other
inmates he wants his smoking privileges
back and he should be allowed to use the
prison library which also consists of a
computer with access to the internet the
prison warden is not cooperative enough
to grant such demands at first but after
frank pulls some strings he agrees then
we see peter being given a cigarette
which prompts him to sign the consent
forms right after the police leave and
he is alone peter ties his shoelace to
his thumb and dislocates it this is the
first step to his perfect escape plan
meanwhile max is worried that he is
going to receive bone marrow from a
criminal like peter his father asserts
that receiving blood from an old person
doesn't make you old likewise peter's
sins have nothing to do with his body in
the prison peter continues the
preparations and approaches a secret
drug supplier the man doesn't want to do
business with him until peter threatens
him he wants an ampule of an anti-drug
named narcan used to treat people who
have od'd the supplier asks what he
wants to use the drug for and peter
claims that everyone will know in time
while the supplier works on getting his
hands on the drug peter uses the library
computer to study the map of the
hospital he's going to be at he tricks
the guards by pretending to play chess
because he is equally good at it they
never suspect him any nerd that good at
chess can't be dangerous in the meantime
the police force prepares the hospital
for peter's arrival and ensures complete
safety there will be several helicopters
flying above and an army will escort him
to and back from the hospital a night
before the big day the supplier gives
peter his daily dose of medicine but he
hands him two cups one of which contains
the drug he asked for alone in his cell
peter ties the ampule to a thread and
ties the other end to his teeth he then
swallows the ampoule to pull it out when
he needs it after that finally comes the
day of the transplant hundreds of guards
in several vehicles bring peter to the
hospital he is taken to the or in
restraints but they have to be removed
when he is kept on the bed the guards do
not waste time before tying his hands
again unaware of his dislocated thumb
the doctor sedates him to initiate the
transplant but just then peter drinks
the content of the ampule the anti-drug
prevents him from passing out which
shocks the doctors as well but by the
time they catch up to his plan he has
already pulled his hand out he uses a
gas pipe to attack the doctors and
guards in the room before making a run
for it frank who had been watching the
commotion from the upper floor runs to
their aid he helps them before turning
his attention towards the fugitive peter
slides down the laundry chute and wears
a doctor's coat to disguise himself as
one despite having a chain tying his
legs together and a gunshot wound on his
leg the man isn't worried he goes to a
room with laser guns and threatens a
doctor to break the chains with them
after that he runs to the emergency room
to get a shot of morphine for the pain
but frank catches him in the act peter
holds a scalpel to max's dr samantha's
throat and demands that frank give up
when the detective tries to shoot peter
samantha reveals that if he dies the
bone marrow will be useless and max will
never get the transplant suddenly a
policeman named wilson appears from
behind the curtain he points his gun at
peter asking him to let the doctor go in
a moment of panic frank gives up his gun
to peter so he can defend himself the
act ensures his departure from the
police force but all he cares about is
saving his son as wilson and peter
negotiate frank comes in between them
refusing to let peter get hurt a
shootout ensues where the fugitive kills
another policeman and hurts wilson
gravely before running away when the
captain arrives with his team he berates
frank for letting people get killed for
his son's life frank is arrested for his
erratic behavior and is to be sent to
the police station however when they are
outside the hospital he throws the
policemen into a crowd of reporters and
escapes back inside max bleeds from his
nose and dr samantha is tending to him
officer matthew is also with the two but
is attacked and knocked out by peter he
demands that samantha reveal where the
cyclo propane is kept in the hospital he
also promises max that he will send her
back as soon as she helps him find what
he wants not wasting any more of his
time frank drives a bike into the
hospital and continues looking for peter
he goes to max and makes sure the kid is
okay before helping matthew max reveals
that the fugitive was talking about
propane which gives frank an idea of
where they might have gone keeping
matthew to take care of the kid he runs
outside at the same time peter makes
samantha put two tanks of propane into a
bag and asks for directions to the
electrical room he is planning to blow
up the place as a distraction to escape
without getting caught however samantha
takes him by surprise and hurts him
before running away she meets frank in
the hallway who begs her not to tell the
police because they will kill peter the
doctor agrees and goes to tend to max
peter and frank meet outside the room
with propane but peter has an upper hand
because frank cannot kill him he blows
up the room and runs away yet again the
explosion also causes the entire
electrical system of the hospital to
shut down including the ventilators and
the lights matthew moves max to the old
building of the hospital joined to the
new one through a bridge while trying to
follow them frank notices that peter is
also moving to the old building as he
crosses the bridge the team below starts
firing at the criminal but frank saves
his life by shooting at the light they
are using to locate him by now the swat
team has entered the hospital which
means peter doesn't have long before he
is either caught or killed to gain
leverage over the other guards he holds
their team leader hostage this allows
him access to the control room which he
uses to put the entire hospital into
lockdown by closing all the doors
meanwhile samantha is told that the kid
is in desperate need of a doctor and she
needs to be in the old building as soon
as possible frank hides her from
everyone and gets her to the other
building gaining an appreciation for his
efforts from peter who is watching them
on cctv cameras still he doesn't allow
him inside the building frank manages to
convince him to let them in promising to
be on his side after being let inside
frank and samantha go to see max while
peter plays at the next part of his plan
he brings the hostages on the roof as a
distraction knowing that the captain and
his team will be on the bridge joining
the buildings he has laid a tank of
propane near the bridge to kill them
frank figures out his plan and saves the
captain and his team's lives by blasting
the propane when they are not on the
bridge now the only people in the
building are peter frank matthew max and
samantha the latter three are inside a
locked room outside peter and frank meet
each other and peter threatens to kill
him max quickly opens the door to save
his father but ends up being held at
gunpoint because of it peter then acts
out the last part of his plan and uses
the kid as a hostage they go to the
morgue which has a weight of the tunnels
underground this was peter's original
escape plan all along as he had the map
of the tunnel he acquired from the
internet he makes a hole in the wall and
apologizes to the kid he would have
helped him if he could without wasting a
chance at freedom peter then leaves max
there and runs through the tunnel with
only half an hour left to sunrise he is
sure to be lost in the rush hour traffic
having found out his plan frank follows
him closely and sees him driving away in
a blue vehicle he steals a police car
and uses the policeman's id to ask for
help from the control room after driving
for several minutes he finally sees the
car about to get on a bridge calling the
bridge operator frank pretends to be the
captain and manages to trap peter again
as they face each other in a showdown
the captain and his team appear on a
helicopter they fire at the criminal but
frank takes the bullet to save him when
peter tries running away again frank
shoots him causing him to fall into the
sea with his remaining strength frank
saves peter and is brought back to the
hospital the transplant finally takes
place and max is saved he returns to
consciousness to a happy father waiting
for him in another more secure ward
peter is still alive he asks the guard
if the kid is okay suddenly the bed
starts moving forward and the guard
realizes his gun is missing the movie
ends as peter holds the gun to his head
and inquires what kind of car he drives
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching